[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosen bomb Ryan we just had an
intense interview we had a couple
intense interviews yeah I'm exhausted
mentally physically me too yeah I feel
like uh it they were they were great
they were really great I can't wait for
you to hear I'm not going to tell you
who we interviewed but um you're going
to really dig
it uh thanks for listening to us thanks
for listening to this podcast I know
there's a lot of podcasts but I hope you
you continue to choose this one um the
the uh the handles if you want to follow
us which is very important at inside
ofup podcast on the Instagram and
Facebook at inside pod on the Twitter
you can watch on YouTube um appreciate
it please write a review helps the show
and uh join patreon p a t r e o n
patreon.com inside of you if you want to
support the podcast give back and help
there so many people that do that it's
become a big family you get to ask
questions to guests you get to um you
get boxes sent from me with notes and
tons of other stuff and perks and bonus
episodes with me and Ryan All That Jazz
but uh patreon.com inside you um and you
can go to the inside you online store
for awesome merch there's tons of cool
merch there's New Lex Luthor shirts I
could say anything I want now the
strike's over tovil podcast.com you can
go get uh the new Prince signed by me
and Tom only a limited amount left so a
lot of cool stuff there and thanks for
supporting the podcast and the tville
podcast Tom and I really appreciate it
and Ryan Ryan's a integral part um what
else we got um go to my Instagram the
Michel Rosen mom if you want to see
where I'm going cons what have you um
going to Nashville creation con Tom and
I are doing a Smallville nights private
event so get tickets they're selling out
and
also um I don't know if I could say this
yet I'm saying it uh I'm doing another
live podcast and the guest is Kristen
Ritter Breaking
Bad uh Jessica Jones the list goes on
she's a brilliant actress and she's a
good friend and she's going to be on the
live podcast with me January 24th at the
Regency Theater downtown Los Angeles get
tickets it is there's going to be meet
and greet there's going to be a lot of
fun I might just bring back the T-shirt
the T-shirt gun oh that was hit I think
I almost killed someone over
there um what else but the link tree at
the Michael Rosen bomb for everything
I'm doing Cameo all that stuff and uh
yeah here we are here we are Ryan and we
have a great guest today she was
actually on Smallville Smallville was
like one of her first roles which we
talk about and uh she's done so much
since I mean Friday Night Lights the
Orville um and she gets she gets deep
and personal as well I really love love
this it was fun chatting with her I
think you're going to really enjoy this
if you don't know her you're going to
learn about her and I think that's part
of the podcast right it's like you may
not know someone but there's going to be
a good conversation you hope and you're
going to learn something from it yeah so
yeah we're all about learning here we're
all about learning we are let's get
inside Adrien Peli it's my
of you're to inside of you with Michael
Rosen
B
[Music]
inside of you with Michael rosenbom was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience you know we reunited at a con I
hadn't seen you in a long time and you
were so sweet and fun and just a
pleasure to be around I was like oh like
I felt like oh sometimes you see people
and you're like oh you know they the the
industry got to them or uh uh you know
divorce got to them or food got to them
or drugs we could go on there's a lot of
things that but I I I looked at you know
I was like she looks great she's uh she
has a good she's a good state of mind
and um but how are you seriously are you
um are you feeling good these days are
you a little stressed because of the
strike are you um what are you doing to
keep saying uh I've been working on
stuff um you
know things that that are being made
after this happens so you know I don't
know I think I'm just so isolated here
from everything so I'm just been
focusing on hanging with friends and my
dog and you know yeah long walks around
the lake and
texme
TexMex really we got we got a lot of it
here we have some of the best
restaurants in the world in Austin give
me the best restaurant that I I would
like that's not too f fancy that's just
a good steak barbecue place okay steak
and barbecue will probably be separate
as far as well barbecue is have
steak uh you know everybody loves
Franklin's here I just think there's a
lot of uh hype around it it is good it
is good but I prefer Black's
Barbecue and um J Carver just opened
here as far as Stak goes and it's pretty
damn good really but ATX CA is probably
my favorite restaurant here but hey look
did you always want to do this did you
always want to be an actor is it
something that you you I have a feeling
you you know you're a beautiful person
so you probably did modeling at a young
age I I didn't look this up I'm just
assuming you were tall and pretty and
you probably did some modeling am I
right I did okay eventually when I
stopped looking like you know I was
knock KN and I had a fro
really my parents decided to come cut my
hair really short and it's really curly
so yes and my sister had a mullet and I
was like what were you guys doing
torturing us slowly I don't know but
yeah no I was uh if I showed you a
picture you would be like oh you were
the cutest little boy I've ever seen um
but yes when I finally went you know
through puberty and my my knees
straightened out I uh I was very tall
and so I started modeling and because I
looked at it as like a way out you know
from Toledo Ohio I was like like what
can I do that gets me out of this city
and and how old were you when you were
thinking these things I was seven when I
when I uh figured out I wanted to act
but that was probably about 14 was when
I was like really like scheming 14 was
when you wanted to get out of there oh
yeah like I I I didn't even think about
it I just thought Indiana this is where
I guess it all happens this is the world
that I live in and I'm Never Gonna Leave
it nor do I think I should because
what's out there I've been to my
grandma's house in New York and it's a
big city but I so I never it's amazing
that you had that much you know that
feeling at such a young age to want to
get out of there don't you feel like
that's a little weird I yeah I don't
know I feel very lucky because as hard
of an industry as it is to break into
and stay in it like you know at least I
knew what I wanted to
do
um but yeah but the thing that sucked
about it too is like I was 14 so I had
so many more years to go before I was
actually able to leave it so I just had
this angst all the time I was like I
gotta get out I gotta get out I gotta
get out yeah and then did you get into
did you get into like drugs or alcohol
at a young age were you ever into that
stuff like in high school no oh I was so
type A I was a straight A student
National Honor Society drama club wow
opposite of me
I was so so yeah I didn't lose my
virginity until I was 18 me too I
remember I remember coming back from
LA and I dyed my hair black I had
tattoos I had sex I was smoking a
cigarette and my sister
goes oh thank
God you were such a straight arrow and
yeah I just kind of went the other way
wow I guess sometimes it happens like
you know especially in the industry you
you look like for instance I remember
seeing this actress actor you say actor
now we don't see actress correct I don't
know I always still say actress okay
good so we'll say actress today but I
remember seeing her and going oh she's
so cute she's so sweet that's the kind
of girl next door I like you know and
then I met this
person hung out with this person and
they did everything in their power power
to destroy that sweet cute wholesome
girl I'm going to pole dance I am GNA
ride a tat tat cuz I never hesitate to
put a fool on his back I am going to I
am going to be like have an attitude I'm
G it was just like I was like snort
cocaine off a hooker well I don't know
about that that was that's you went over
the line on that one but no you didn't
but so I understand what it's like to
kind of fight that that side of you that
you're like H I'm the nerd I'm this in
high school I couldn't get you know I
didn't get any action and now I have a
chance to get out and and explore and be
dark and have a cigarette and like I
think you have to go through that don't
you absolutely absolutely I was actually
I'm gonna be honest with you I was just
more afraid of getting knocked up when I
was younger because I was like I wanted
nothing to keep me in toita it's a great
place to be from by the way yeah oh it's
also a great place to
leave um I think I was just more afraid
of
that this show is sponsored by better
help Ryan you ever feel like your brain
is getting in the way of living your
best life all the time yeah I would say
so like you know what you should do
what's good for you but you you just
can't seem to do it oh yeah yeah therapy
helps you figure out what's holding you
back so your brain can work for you
instead of against you and this is what
happens with um therapy you're you have
all these things bottled up and you need
to let them out and you need to talk to
a professional it really really helps
therapy is a great way to learn positive
coping skills and how to set boundaries
it empowers you to be the best version
of yourself and it's way more convenient
with better help it's entirely online
and designed to be convenient flexible
and suited to your schedule just fill
out a brief questionnaire it took me
like a minute it's so easy even I can do
it then you get matched with a licensed
therapist switch therapist anytime for
no additional charge seriously it's not
uncommon you meet someone you're like I
want to try someone else it's easy just
like that better help is truly the best
way to make your brain your friend give
it a try visit betterhelp.com
inside today to get 10% off your first
month that's betterhelp
hp.com
inside inside of you is brought to you
by discover if you like using debit over
credit don't you think it's time you
also get rewarded well now you can with
discover cashback debit it's a checking
account that rewards everyone with cash
back on everyday purchases plus there
are no fees period we're talking date
nights thrifting the latest trends
nights out with your friends and it's
now earning you cash back with discover
cashback deit check out eligibility and
terms at discover.com
slashback deit Discover Bank member
FDIC did you were you close with your
parents still close with my parents
still close with your parents they still
live there I don't know why my sister
lives in Houston my brother lives in
Seattle it's just not it's just not easy
to get to you had to fly to Detroit
there's a drive it's a it's a whole wait
a minute why can't you fly to
Cleveland because Cleveland's way
further than
Detroit and Detroit are like this
they're like how far is Toledo from
Cleveland yeah from Detroit Detroit from
Toledo it's about 30 minutes oh that's
not bad it's just a 35 so it's a direct
flight and a quick
drive that sounds like hell though to
you how often do you go see your parents
I was just there I was actually just
there for like three days and that was
perfect you know it's not it's like my
dad and
I tight he's he's my buddy right and
then my mom and I am like three days is
perfect what is it about your mother
that drives you crazy because I could
talk about mine too oh my God her
anxiety it is like she will find things
to worry about oh it is unbelievable
I've never seen anything like it do you
know if I had something if I had top
five quotes my mother has said in her
life number
five I'm
dying number four your father's an
[__] number three I can't I just
can't deal with it anymore I can't
number two um I need money and the
number one answer I don't know I don't
know what number one would be I should
have kept number five as number
one yeah they're all pretty good but
she's always she's always got anxiety
she's always got she's always dying
she's her knee is in pain she's like I'm
dying I'm in agony I go mom I want you
to look up the word agony are you in
[__]
Agony I've had eight spine surgeries and
I'm not in agony am I in pain do I have
pains yes uncomfortable am I UNC do I
have discomfort but I'm dying I can't
deal with it anymore I go mom you have
been dying since I was
born and that's the truth so it's hard
it is hard to be around like you said
three days two or three days I love I
love you Mom but I'm [__]
out I am not gonna I'm gonna lose my
mind yeah I might I might kill you yeah
and I don't want that you know no you
don't want to kill your mom that would
be bored Ryan
so Ryan's close with his family but no
you're close you just your mom drives
you crazy you love her you're close with
your parents but you know it's like yes
I I get it I get it um has this did you
ever think when you were you started
modeling and you were doing all these
fun things did you ever think I'm gonna
make it I'm gonna be an actor I'm gonna
be known I'm gonna be famous I'm gonna
make money did you honestly did you ever
think like that I did good for you to
say that I well and you know of course
you're young so you're like I'm by this
age gonna get this by age 28 I'm going
to have an Emmy and an Oscar and all you
know what I mean of course it was like
this thing by 30 I'm going to be married
it's like all of these you know things
and then you get in the real world and
you're like that's not how this works
yeah um and I really like weirdly when I
first started in Hollywood too I had
this version of course because it was
like you know the time of before cell
phones it was the time of photographers
following you around and and [__] like
that so it was like I had this weird
thing in my head was like well if you
don't have photographers following you
around then obviously you're not
successful you know it was just this
really weird like you know I should be
like Lindsay loan but nobody wants that
um
but that shifted I mean that shifted
when I was like really working and going
I like to do this and I also like my
life that's why I live in
Austin you know what I mean so you
stopped wanting to you weren't chasing
Fame anymore you were just enjoying the
moment yes
and it took me some time to get there
though that takes time because you kind
of uh Revel in it or whatever you kind
of uh just want to be noticed and have
attention and things that I didn't get
as a kid and and all of a sudden you get
that and you get that and you realize
it's kind of just comes and goes and no
one really cares and but I still like I
still like getting recognized I don't I
don't it doesn't phase me but it go I I
still go that's cool cool that's nice no
there's definitely an appreciation for
it absolutely it just doesn't Define my
life anymore because that's the thing
too I mean I know you guys are in LA but
that's what I don't love about it is the
incestuous nature of the city that every
single person pretty much is in one
industry it's like even if you're a
lawyer you're you know working for a
studio it just so everything's measured
everything's a dick measuring contest
right oh I went on this audition today I
got this I got this you know what I mean
all your friends you're like yeah you
start to really have a lot of self-hate
because you're like I measuring myself
based on other people and their
successes you know yeah I I I get that
um I think that you know for so long
it's like when people come up to you and
they're like hey so what's
new and for so long it was like oh well
I got this going on and I got this going
on and and I think this is going to
happen and I'm probably going to do this
and you just had to always feel
important and I swear to God everything
has shifted where people are like uh hey
what are you up to I'm like you know
what I'm just enjoying life I'm just
enjoying whatever I do trying to have an
element of fun in anything I do I'm just
trying to
be you know present present you have a
large body of work and you're still very
young but you've done so much I I do
want to just briefly talk
about uh when you were on the show that
I was on where I played the bald guy uh
I just want to know it is interesting
seeing you with hair yeah and by the way
I'm getting haircut today it's all over
the freaking Place good thanks but um
who would have thought you had so much
of it yeah I I was hoping that my hair
would eventually grow I wouldn't that be
sort of like you you shave your head for
seven years and then you're bald and
your hair and I used to worry but Greg
Beaman who was a producer and director
on on the show I love Greg I love Greg
he said to me yeah because he directed
you he said to me hey just thinkk Rosen
bomb everybody else on this show will
look the same when they they leave but
not you you'll have hair and I
go God
damn I always thought that then it gave
me a little bit like okay that's good
something people to say yeah but what
was your time what was it like on there
were you nervous at all coming on
because this was like one of your first
big things right oh my God it was the
first thing I ever did that actually
aired i' done like a pilot at that point
oh this might have been my second paying
job I mean there was one and it was not
a porn but it's definitely not on my
IMDb because it's that you know horror
movie that you always just you're like I
got paid to do that but I never need to
see it and other people don't either so
it's kind of like the third paying job
and not only
that an said whatever we were on um the
first day on set I had to be in a pasty
pasties and a thong oh my boy
walk
through the woods in Vancouver and I
want to say it was like October or
November it was freaking cold but I was
also like hey crew here's me
naked
including you know Tom who had to open
the door and like literally was looking
anywhere but at me yeah uncomforable
yeah and by the way every crew member to
this day says it was the best stay in
the history of their film making
oh seeing you in the woods with pasties
but you know what I remember this I
remember just hearing how cool you were
and what a sport you were and how fun
funny you were that's what I remember I
don't remember like oh man she's hot or
this I remember everybody just really
liking you oh that's cool well it's true
it's true you're a fun person and you're
a team player and uh so yes the first
time you meet Tom I guess you're you're
supposed to play this naked girl who's
supposedly from
Krypton correct correct and were you
nervous of
course of course Tom's
hatot Tom's hat I heard the Toledo
accent I heard your Toledo accent Tom's
hat my God he's from freaking Toledo
um he is hot you know U but you were hot
you're still hot you know I'm met you at
this slutting Place yep when I was
shooting the first thing I ever did
which was a pilot which was before then
so I actually the you made me feel so
comfortable because going on to it I
already knew you see we met at we met at
the hot tubs the hot tubs yeah I was
running like CU I I used to go to the
hot tub late at night where there was
nobody there it was completely empty and
I'd sit in the hot tub and I just learn
my lines by myself and nobody would be
there and occasionally if there was
somebody there I would just stop
obviously learning lines and just sit
there and if they stayed too long I'd
leave but I remember I think I was
learning lines and then you you came
into the hot tub yep but I I think at
one point I helped you learn your lines
yeah I think you
did I think you actually initiated and
said hey you want to read you want to
read that like you were cool about it as
I recall but it's good memory
what when you watched the episode were
you you were you really excited because
it was one of the best episodes ever oh
uh yeah well I've only seen it once and
it was when it
aired and my
manager my managers put together kind of
a little screening
party which I don't know about you I I
don't love watching myself especially in
front of other people definitely not for
the first time yeah I have to know if
it's good or not right yeah it's like
cringy I get really uncomfortable oh man
it's it's the worst when you haven't
seen something and you're watching
you're just mic judging it the entire
time uhuh yeah that's nerve-wracking I
don't like that I don't like people
being onet I don't like people visiting
me while I'm working I don't like I
didn't even watch small that small show
that I was on for a while I good there
yeah I I I watched occasionally but like
now doing that rewatch it's like
watching for the first time is it's so
crazy now and I I appreciate it and all
that but um but it's cool that you were
a part of that you were a part of that
sort of Mythos is that what they call it
you know that sort of Superman
lore um it was cool but then you went
off and did a big show the football show
let me tell you something I think I told
you this or maybe not I didn't watch the
show show when it first came out I
didn't watch the
show till
about I want to say 5 years ago and my
friends swore by it and I go Chris
remember Chris uhhuh we went to the mall
together yep yep I said Chris come on
man it's like high school it's like I
don't he goes Rosen bomb dude you gotta
watch it trust me you got you'll like it
I was hooked it is such a good show if
you haven't seen it it is every
performance is
so just it's it's a it's a it's a show
that should go down history as one of
the great great shows of television in
history it's in the top 10 it is who
judged that I guess New York Times or I
don't know somebody well good and yeah
it was honestly it was the best thing in
the it taught me how to really act
because you know Peter Berg handpicked
everybody on purpose for the reasoning
that he
wanted people to just be raw and
improv and you know like you would walk
into a room and there were three cameras
no
marks and just be like
go and then sometimes you know he'd
whisper something and then our EP
director ended up doing this as well
Jeff Reiner but like you know whisper
something in my ear and then go to plem
and whisper something in his ear and we
say whatever it is and then all of a
sudden we have this whole different
Dynamic going and then we go into the
lines and it just created this really
cool environments
to to work and it was really hard to
relearn how to you know walk up to a
mark seriously that what a great gift to
go in and go hey we know the lines and
let's go play a little bit let's go play
and let's improvise if we feel like it
and at what I mean what a great
environment and you're doing it all in
film you're shooting on film yeah we
were shooting on film and you know I met
some of my best friends on that show
Connie Britain's still one of my dearest
friends in the world she's like a sister
who did she play she was not the Le mom
the mom I forgot the names of people I
forget the names of people she's
amazing I loved
her
too honestly everybody was great like
there isn't a bad I can't think of one
performance where I'm like H and I'm
sure there was some but like most of
these performances were just Dynamite
what like did
you when you look back and you're acting
with Jesse
plens Yeah my buddy can
you remember
thinking he's going to be a big star
this this guy is really great or just
thinking like he's good he's good
honestly no I really
thought to me he always felt like if um
Philip Seymour Hoffman and Matt Damon
had a baby that's what he would look
like and you know with that kind of
energy and I knew even when he was I
mean he was one of the youngest but he
was still like my buddy you know what I
mean he was a good hang and he was like
17 or something when we started that
show and yeah I looked at him I was just
like he's going to be huge
and here he is winning Awards and you
still talk to him yeah you
do yes well it's been a long time I
didn't know if you were still close yeah
I'm still close I know him I know his
his gal hiron and um they come to Austin
quite I think they actually might buy a
place here because you know he's from
Waco
so um yeah no I talk to them I talked to
I talked to a lot of the people Kyle
lives in Dripping Springs with his
family Kyle
does I you think Kyle would ever do the
podcast I love Kyle oh god he's a hoot
he's so good as that
coach it was
like I don't you can't be more likable
and cool than that dude oh and you know
what okay here's a story for you so
Linda Loy our casting director who's
brilliant right uh does everything for
for peterg peterg wanteded Dwight Yokum
oh that would have been tough a tough
character it would have been a very
different character different show and
she was like listen you have to see this
guy you have to see this guy and Peter
will tell you the story um and he's like
no he was that guy on that show with the
newspap ah he's too pretty he's too
pretty he's a pretty boy I don't want to
see him she's like listen we have to put
up more than one person you know what I
mean like you let's just just just other
people are coming in for sessions just
let them come
in and his hair was exactly how his hair
was on the show he took off his ball cap
he's like hey how y'all doing okay and
he just looked like he had had like too
many beers the night before and he was
just his hair was like this just
arai and Peter was like dude I'm sold
he's he's the guy he's the guy because
honestly I don't know that that show
would have been what it was if it had
been somebody other d y i love Dwight
Yokum and he's a great singer and he's a
great actor but Dwight Yokum is good for
a supporting character in a show not the
lead [__] coach that would have been
the worst decision ever there's I mean
what would have happened is the coach
would have died in the first season and
then they would had a new coach yes well
this is why we also have casting
directors now you've done all these
shows and you're doing one now now and
uh it's you know it has to deal with
space and a ship uh that no no longer
doing that that got cancelled we only
did three seasons is it not going
anymore I don't know truly the answer to
that I think that there's the talk that
it could possibly be something that
certain people want to
do but it's a really difficult show to
shoot man it is we shot 33 episodes in
six years 33 episodes in six years
how is that
possible that's 33 ided 6 is 5.2
episodes a
year was it
expensive okay so you're getting paid
the same as an actor so if you're only
doing five episodes It's not really
worth your time no it became an actual
real issue because there would be so
much time in
between uh between seasons CU Seth
wanted to write
everything um himself so it would just
take so much time and at one point we
were like we have to like fight the
studio to like give us a holding fee or
something because you know Jay Lee was
eating Saltines and Gatorade at one
point because we just couldn't afford
anything it was horrible wow I had no
idea wait so you play hockey did you
ever play with with uh my ex-husband
Scott GR
um I don't think I've played with Scott
GMS but I knew him from years ago big
hockey guy yeah also met on that show
which is great because he's still one of
my best friends in the world so he still
friends after you got divorced yeah he
just text me right now we're planning
how going on a trip that is unbelievable
how do you get married and then
immediately get divorced and still are
best friends that doesn't make sense it
doesn't I know honestly I think being
thrust back in into like another season
of the show after everything we started
off as best Pals so we were you know
always just you know doing weird stuff
to each other on set not that sounded
that sounded dirty I didn't mean that
like that we were just always picking on
each other playful very playful yeah
playful right right right and then you
know one day we just hook up yeah it was
really good and then that just kind of
became this thing that we were sneaking
for a year
on the show and then it escalated into
what it probably shouldn't have you
know so we tried it didn't work well
good for you you're mature two people
that are mature that appreciate each
other it didn't work out the way they
thought and gave it a shot moving
on I don't have more fun with anyone
outside of my sister in the world he is
so fun we just sit there and laugh I
remember liking him I just haven't seen
him in so long but I remember going I
like that guy I remember liking him I
just don't know him well enough like if
we saw each other like dude hey it's
been forever but yeah I like him um and
I love that he loves hockey because I'm
a big hockey fanatic um so you don't
want to talk about the oral anymore that
that's that sounds like you just don't
really want to talk about that no I
loved it did your character
die no you're like a I listen Okay so I
did I did love so many things about it I
think it was the process that was hard
the process was difficult but I love the
people I work with and I love the crew
they're my
family
um hard it was it was taxing it was
taxing for for what you got out of it it
was it was it was a lot of work for
right little do you ever get Star Struck
is there an actor that you have worked
with where you just you're like oh my
gosh I can't believe I'm working with
this and it's kind of like going to
interfere with your work and you're just
like I'm not going to let it interfere
with my work but you're a little bit
enamored uh yeah who harri
elways really from Princess Bride that's
why because it's the that's the movie
that made me want to be an actor did you
tell him that you were Star Struck I did
eventually of course because he loved to
tell stories too about people
and um but what I was doing was a pilot
and my character was the main
person and did David E Kelly have
anything to do with it uh-huh and so
when he came in they wanted me to read
with him and I didn't
know that he was coming in and when he
walked in I was like
uh I just looked at the cast director
I'm like you have to read because I
don't want to blow this for him and oh
my God I'm so nervous I was shaking I
was like I don't even know what to do
right now and he and by the way the
nicest maybe the nicest human in the
world you know I was thinking what what
about working with jensenackles and
Jared pedi did you enjoy that were they
fun to work with those
[__] um I love those guys and by the
way they live here yeah you know yep yes
um no they're just they're fantastic and
honestly I'll say that when I
did the show initial thing um the first
episode I was really bummed because I
was so aware of the fact that I wasn't
coming back to the show because we had
just such a great time and everybody was
we were still kids you know especially
uh Jared he was a baby yeah he was a
baby so um yeah talk to me about having
to deal with I know you've talked about
it a lot but like this show we deal with
mental health we deal with all sorts of
[__] and it really helps people and I
know that you have dealt with celiac
disease and it's real right like it's
real I I don't think people quite
understand you know some people are like
oh I I don't eat gluten and people oh
gosh gluten you know here we go with the
gluten thing and I'm like I first of all
I'll say when I don't have gluten and I
don't have dairy I feel significantly
better significantly so tell me tell me
exactly what it does to you and what
happens when you do take things you're
not supposed to take or eat okay well I
found out on the when I was in Texas
doing the thing about football um I got
really really really sick Connie and I
would go out and eat every night and it
was just you know whatever was amazing
which is everything here and I just
started to get like really bad stomach
pains like almost like I feel like I
might know what being shot feels like
whoa like I would have pills pain pills
that I mean I'd be driving and I would
be writhing in pain on the side of a
road for sometimes an
hour um and it was was never consistent
and then I started dropping a ton of
weight and I had this belly sleeping 14
hours a day still didn't feel like I was
sleeping and then the really freaky
thing was I couldn't walk up a flight of
stairs I was so out of out of
breath so I finally went to the doctor
and he gave me a blood test and I had
absolutely no B
vitamin I was so anemic uh I almost
needed I was like
0.001 away from needing a blood
transfusion no vitamin D anything so it
almost it looked virtually like I was
anorexic you know what I mean did he ask
you that yeah he asked me all the
questions I mean again too I'm like
really thin I'm like you don't
understand how much I eat and it just
like I don't know what's going on so he
tested me for a million different things
and I had already kind of self-
diagnosed at that point when I was
younger because I always had tummy
issues and hadn't eaten like anything
kbby I always did really well on that so
I was just like you know would you just
test me for celiac he's like you're
supposed to be born with that if you
were born with it you'd be 4 foot two
and it's an old school way of thinking
and I'm like just listen you're already
testing me for Ms and all this other
[__] you know um sure enough the thing
that came back positive was celiac
and you have to go to a gastroent is's a
whole thing because you're like more
susceptible to like colon cancer and all
those things but yeah it's a real thing
and so it's an ultimately a malnutrition
disorder because it kills the Villi in
your intestines if you have Celiac and
you can't absorb
nutrients so this is why you feel or
felt the fatigue why you weren't gaining
weight why you weren't having the
strength to go up the stairs it was
because of this yes
and what what did you do how hard is it
to get on a specific diet and stick to
it in the beginning it was hard I mean
it's it's so easy now like everybody has
a gluten sensitivity or allergy or
whatever and like most places have
gluten-free you know [__] Austin always
did even when I was first diagnosed they
had a
bakery um but it was it was the sauces I
kept messing up because I didn't realize
that it's like literally in every
sauce so that became kind of a you know
touch Ando thing so it's really hard for
people to start on that but it's just
it's so easy now and sometimes the stuff
tastes better explain how long it took
before you actually go wow I feel like a
different human being now it was a
month I remember the moment that was
like oh is this what feeling good feels
like wow did you feel while you had it
I'm I'm asking these questions because I
notice when I have gluten it just I feel
like [__] I'm dragging I know I have it
I'm dragging I'm I'm just I'm just tired
I and and what about your aches and
pains did you feel like everything was
inflam yes inflamed that's why it's it's
an like it's an inflammatory that's why
they encourage people like with cancer
to not eat it that in Dairy you know
what I mean it's such an inflammatory my
sister moved in with me in LA and I have
a gluten-free
household she still ate every night
either rice or pasta or some kind of
potato cut out gluten but she would just
make gluten-free pasta
whatever every night we eat carbs she
lost 100 pounds in a a
year she lost 30 pounds the first
month by just not having gluten really
yep that was it well what if you don't
want to lose weight eat whatever you
want
exactly if it's gluten-free I mean that
doesn't mean that doesn't mean it's
healthy you know you can still eat
really bad for you gluten-free food you
know I urge everybody just to if you're
like me when I don't like I said if you
just just take like a month off of
having gluten just make sure you just
don't have gluten or dairy just and and
write down how you feel in day one how
you deal how you feel on day 14 and how
you feel on the last day of the month
and I bet you everything that you're
going to notice a huge difference in
your energy levels in your just you're
not going to be as tired you're not
going to have as I'm telling you but for
some reason it's so hard for me to not
when the boys are around have a couple
slices of pizza have a you know have uh
whatever Dairy have and just enjoy life
and I'm like well you're feeling like
[__] though is it worth feeling like
[__] for for a 2 minutes of going oh I
feel this is great yeah no especially
when there's something else you could
eat that's similar you could have a
piece of pizza that's
gluten-free that's just as good and you
don't feel that way yeah it's just not
it's just not as convenient like you
know going on a long
drive is difficult sometimes yeah but do
you you feel substantially better now
you feel great I feel amazing if I have
it if I have it I know I usually will
turn the
fuchsia and then I pretty much have like
the stomach flue for that day 1,00% and
sometimes the last up to three wait a
minute even if you have a little bit
that's what your body does the worst for
me is soy sauce soy sauce you can get
gluten-free soy sauce no tamari it's
literally it's better it just doesn't
have the preservative I mean think about
it soy sauce can sit on your shelf for
years tomorrow you can't yeah because it
doesn't have the wheat that is a
commercial soy sauce can fit on your
shell sit on your shelves for 30 years
tamari can't introducing new
tamari it's so funny oh my God I'm like
I don't know if I want to put something
in my body that can like Outlast me and
still be okay to
use um I love this this is just a fun
conver it started out so boring and then
we've just really because of my
questions they were really boring and we
can cut that though because it's going
to be a really good episode I'm excited
about this look I know you probably
don't believe it but this was actually
turned into one of the most fun times
I've had it really just felt it was just
kind of
fun yeah anytime it really was I've been
wanting you to come on here for a long
time and I'm I'm glad we finally did
this me too thank you for asking me to
be on yes thank you where's Tom uh what
do you mean where's Tom Tom do we do the
other don't you guys do your your
podcasty thing together oh yeah we have
the other podcast that we do we have the
tville
podcast gotcha this is fantastic are you
going to be any cons coming
up not till
May Nashville
Nashville huh are you going to
Nashville going to Nashville Nashville
when are you going to Nashville I don't
know I think June or something next year
I don't know no I'm going to Nashville
this year I'm going to Nashville in
December all right yeah well I hope to
see you soon I'm gonna I'm gonna just
text you
regardless yes please and come to Austin
and I'll text you when I'm back in La I
would love that it's nice to know I have
a place to stay in um Austin absolutely
you
do love you love that girl thank you for
being on the podcast it's taken a while
but you took time out of your busy
schedule I mean there was a
strike but uh no I appreciate it it was
it was a lot of fun and I appreciate all
you guys for listening if you really
enjoyed the podcast you're like hey not
bad please follow us and listen to some
more episodes don't just come for Adrian
come for you know for us we're here Ryan
we're people we have banter we have some
banter
like not very good banter
obviously I just thought it would be
funny to just do a really long awkward
pause a long awkward we we do yeah uh
and uh make sure if you want to uh give
back to the podcast in more ways than
one you go to patreon.com / inside you
I'll send you a message thanks for
joining and um you can really help the
podcast believe me it's up to the the
patrons who really support the show to
keep it going so thank you and if you
missed anything listen to the intro or
you can go to my Instagram at the Michel
Rosen mom link tree has everything I'm
doing cameos all that stuff all that
jazz uh right now why don't we get into
it this is the top tier patrons these
are the people that are on the the the
top they give the most to the podcast
and dog on it they get their name
shouted out out so here we go top to
your patrons go to patreon.com inside
you and here we go Nancy D lean Christen
little Lisa Yukiko Jill e Brian H just
saw him at the depes mode cover band
thing raised depes mode convention it
was fun Nico P Robert B Jason W Sophie M
Raj C Joshua D Jennifer N Stacy L Jamal
F Janelle B Mike e l Dan Supremo 99 more
San Diego M Chad W lean P Matty s blinda
n Dave H Sheila G Brad d Ray H Tabitha T
Tom n Talia M Betsy d ranan c Corey K
Dev Nexon Michelle a Jeremy C Brandy D
Joey M Eugene and Sweet Leah Corey
Angela F Mel s Christine s Eric H Shane
R Andrew M Amanda
R Kevin e Stephanie K Jor L jamond J
lean J Luna R Mike f Stone H Brian l
jwes m Kendall L Jessica B Kyle F
Marisol hi Kyle hi Marisol hi Jessica hi
everybody Marisol P Kaylee J Brian a
Ashley F Mar Louise L Romeo the band
Frank B Jen T Nikki L April R Randy s
jdw oral P Ginger Insomniac Rachel D
Laurel L Melissa H Nick W Stephanie and
Evan and Char Charlene a or Charlene but
it's Charlene thank you for being a
supporter of the podcast and helping
this podcast uh couldn't do it without
you we keep doing it because of you so
as long as you guys are here uh I
hopefully won't be going anywhere um
thank you and uh from uh my heart uh I'm
Michael rosenbom from the Hollywood
Hills in California I'm Brian Tails
little way to the camera thank you guys
uh be good to yourself and um all my
love to you I'll see you next week
hopefully you'll tune in thank you
[Music]
p